okay well thanks to the Academy also not
for just acknowledging this movie also
for putting up this program it's feels
really really special to come from
abroad and and doing this week with all
these nice people which are sitting over
there so thank you for for this and also
I have a lot of people to thank I will
try to make it quick the first are my
producers boys into I compliment the
suited film and to be as who burns I've
been who nobody Menelaos from there here
tonight thanks for all your work
my my I have to thank my actress Vincent
Pico dean donnel
you were all great thank you and Jamal
who brought them to me and and the
people who made him look good my costume
designer Dianna DJ my makeup artist
Cristina
byah also my production designer Kanaka
vieng you you such a wonderful woman and
you did a nice job and music was so
important to this to this movie and and
yet the guys who did it they were called
super strings
Calgon mark thank you someday did you
turn us to my post production supervisor
thomas harrot he's here with me tonight
as well thanks for your work yet some
guys from the production Alexander
pfitzenmaier Christophe bear from the
bio wouldn't funk not le lam stove from
art Monica lobkowitz Martin Kovacic of
course the film phantom Bayern they how
does a lot and they're always helping
young people to achieve the goals and
most important of course my University
of television and film Munich my fellow
students which I think I learned a lot
from them and the whole staff professor
Goodman and especially my instructor
professor Gruber was also with me
tonight and he was a supporter of this
movie from the very first moment on and
I really thank you for that I knew it
was a risk to support it of course my
parents mom and dad thank you
my editor uncle and business I learned
so much from you my DP Yan masala Cal
was also with me tonight not only for
dedicating yourself to this project and
putting everything on and always pushing
me to get it better and better and
better but also being the best friend I
have since high school thank you for
that and last but wherever not least my
screenwriter maggie Perrin yes of course
for your talent but also for being my
wife and bearing with me and and having
our son now at home in Munich John oh I
yeah I love you both thank